[Music]
three-two-one we talk about what today
we got whoever we want and we got Nelson
on Wow I'm here what's hood it's your
boy I have allergies so excuse me if I
start crying through the episode what
kind of crying is it it's just been
leaky eyes and it's been happening like
more than ever but this is better than
that one time I was five and I woke up
my eyes work rusted shut
whoa what do you how did you get it out
I was a child my mom just said appeal it
she remember I just know that my mom was
like she wakes up and then I'm just like
because I just thought I was blind I
think we could not open my eyes but
that's never happened since then and I
loved he loved the feeling of good
though oh I do just peeling it out of
going away Oh y'all like scapulars here
no I would pay for that experience I
haven't had a stab in a while you can
relate them no I'm asking peeler no I
know but you'd pay for it you're like
please I would what you know in Vietnam
you could get your ear pick you get your
ear picked
yeah there's ear pickers well you need
to have it because like I have family
members that have excess wax that and
they literally can't hear sometimes I
think you can do that here too I don't
know if they're professionals but I
think you can get it done you know what
you can't get it done five dollars come
on if you wanted too hard no my friend
had that and a doctor pulled out this
gigantic ear bat ear wax ball you know
I've always wanted to do that you know
the thing where they like like you can
go to their doctor and have them take
everything out yeah I hear it's
life-changing you hear more
that's what I've heard
not well but I've heard it yeah a little
bit muffled though I kind of want that
cuz I feel like with like you know how
people like pimple popping and just gab
picking like that's like to me that's
like a it's a different body fluid
whereas earwax just feels like so
harmless like a booger ingrown hair
removal have some [ __ ] up videos out
there oh do but you should stop picking
your scabs cuz there's blood all over
our sheets all the time now you got the
elbow scab that you always constantly
have because it never goes away keep
your elbows because I ran into the
[ __ ] wall yep many time release the
weenus elbows gap no other elbow please
I don't have an elbow scab that doesn't
go away look I see a faint tracing of
what that looks like that's just now
having my elbow like that now yeah why
do you have elbow rug burns is me from
the behind Peggy
you need to wear the professor jackets
and you have nice suede the whole time
when you allergy cry
is it like no it's just it's just like
leaking in fact I'll probably if it
starts happening really bad I'm not
gonna wipe my tears away I'm gonna let
it flow jealous but you just point out
yourself you're gonna see it you're just
like what the [ __ ] is she it just droops
cease it just I just my eyes have just
been watering like non-stop like if I
yawn you'll get a couple tears okay I
had that a couple weeks ago and I would
I I had choppy cry constantly yeah cause
he had a sinus infection I'm just
imagining Nikki Bella sue she sees it
look you know why you kind
true any clear for him and I bet that
felt so good
my dog has that problem he used to
always like every day we would see them
every after like a couple hours you
would have crazy eyed loads all the time
turns out he has allergies maybe they
have traumatic copies yes so many
problems
you sure they're not just sad maybe I
don't want to be with can I just say
that we JK has the best smelling fans I
have ever incorrect in my youtube career
I told you guys we have cool fans you
just do the danger boys how'd that come
from crying no we just did hygiene
hygiene
we were just did a dangerous game and
ton of people show up like 600 people
and you hug them sometimes at YouTube
stuff you smell people it's like mildew
is pretty bad I can get none yeah they
smell like they haven't showered in two
weeks those conditions man the like Oh
VidCon and playlist
oh we hugged every single person there
not one person smelled that everyone
smoked everyone knew how to dress well
they are yeah they were well grew it was
that a college right yeah but they
weren't all college students because it
was open to the public it was thrown by
a frat okay
like I think more than half of the
people there weren't students yeah
they're just locals yeah investing in
deodorant laughs yeah I know it's
important you grown s I wanted to hold
out I wish I could smell them well
because you got YouTube fans most
YouTube fans are like pretty disgusting
I've seen a lot of my other friends
nothing I won't wear though like they
don't bathe they're not a part of the
regular world they stay home a lot they
are there geeky I mean yeah I always
said that JK fans are always the best
because like we don't have those really
like once in a while you'll have someone
with corroded teeth that doesn't know to
like leave you alone and whatever okay
okay my that's just the world yeah dude
my first year at twitchcon and this is
like I like I just had like 20 viewers
or so I don't know me more now because I
actually had some people that recognized
to me there and it was my first time
ever dealing with fans this was like
four years ago and I remember like I was
like oh hey you know we took pictures
whatever and they were like cool where
are we going and I was like you're not
coming with me yeah like they'll just
they would they'd like I've never had to
deal with this sense it was just first
year twitchcon but like the student was
just like yeah where are we going and it
was like his little entourage of like
four friends and like I walked away and
they just like followed like two feet
behind but it was post enough that they
were like yeah with her and I was like
all right well I'm gonna go get lunch
they were like dope we're and almost
like don't know yet but I gotta go to my
hotel first okay so like Twitter no I'm
good like it was really [ __ ] it was
one should get scary though cuz I so a
lot of these tubers when they were in
high school they were not cool nobody
cared about over like them they couldn't
get girls right then all of a sudden
they get this level the doing YouTube
[ __ ] in their basement and then they
meet these girls who are like where are
we going and these guys like my room
just like the age they were rejected by
it so like it gets really cheesy I see
this good word I like that because when
you say something gets dicey I don't
know if it's good or bad cuz I'm dumb
but I like it cuz I don't know how I
feel about you mean dicey or you mean
like risky I'm talking like oh boy dicey
okay I'm going all-in I'm gonna start
saying that's the guy see just like I
kept saying like oh no okay so less and
I was drunk and I was playing overwatch
and I saw this tweet that reminded me of
something and I can't stop using horny
as an adjective like I would go into
these overwatch games and I'd be like
alright guys let's make some horny plays
and they were like what the [ __ ] but
horny such a funny word
everyone dies and you have the point
you're like dude guys so [ __ ] horny
this guy delivers horny better than
anybody at sea I'll be like oh she's way
too horny trav you use in both good
situations and bad situation huh I'm so
horny right now no that's me I'm saying
like in a situation but something bad it
could be like aw dude I'm sorry to hear
that that's so warning oh my god I
didn't know that's really horny that's
horny as [ __ ] don't be so Hardy dude
yeah more of the story don't advise
boughs to advise invite balls to any
funerals that view earlier I know she's
like God you guys are so horny it's cuz
grief like makes you horny dude also I
have heard that but I've also only heard
that from you so also guys if you could
both tells you she meets you whatever
and she tells you she's horny it doesn't
exactly mean that now we know ok cool
that was that your first stray-dog
experience cuz we stray dog fans happen
a lot there's a term I love this term
yeah like it's like picking up a stray I
know exactly yeah and it's not it's not
unusual for that [ __ ] to happen yeah 88
rising concert remember it was a random
straggler that came along and then I was
like hey is your right here to pick you
up yeah yeah I remember I was like I
suppose they're like hey I think you're
right here yeah it's like what and I'm
like yeah like how are you getting home
we do have a lot of hugs let's trade up
strange stragglers I don't know but yeah
I experienced that quite a few at Anime
Expo and it's like I get it you know
it's the crowd it's like a good chunk of
our like demographic but one time I was
stuck in a line because I really wanted
to buy something and the line was taking
forever and this guy was like oh hey
you're so so like yeah nice to meet you
was like yeah cool
and then we were just like standing
there for like a good like solid minute
I'm not saying anything and he was like
oh you know so what do you plan on
getting here I'm like oh just this and I
just want to keep it short because he
just wanted to like me
a really long conversation and I was
like dude man I really don't want to
talk about work right now I'm just
trying to have fun that's the thing
sometimes I'll stand there and I'll
stare at them like this see that but me
and they'll just stare back at me if
they don't have good social cues you
know they'll just look at me and into
walk away there are some people though
that I do want to continue talking to
and I'm like wait I do want to hang out
with you so now they're gonna see this
and be like I'll just leave home are
just interests like some people are like
I'll be like well talk and and maybe
they'll say something like yeah I own a
freaking farm and I'm like really what
the [ __ ] tell me more yeah yeah like I
don't want to bother you and they walk
away on my [ __ ] I don't even know what
you grow we're the opposite we're the
opposite cuz if somebody's like yeah I
have a farm I like yeah yeah see you
later dude no I think I'm more
interested in hearing what other people
would have to say versus me talking
about myself cuz to me I'm like do I
feel like I talk tired yeah I'm tired
like I don't mean I don't yeah yeah
interesting Beyonce wait oh yeah okay I
want to know more about you you you tell
me what's up with you like I don't want
to talk about me when Steve's channel
was really popping off with like the
pranks he was doing it was kind of
annoying because every single fan was
trying to prank him so like and they
would try to involve me in it they'd be
like oh I'm gonna troll ski because he
always told me but it's gonna be tight
and I'm like literally like you're the
fifth person today to do this they don't
know theirs so they were so bad at it
what's the worst one the most common one
was hey Steve can I get a picture and
then they would pull up their phone and
take a picture or they would hand me
their phone and then have me take a
picture of that more whatever is the
idea right that's so stupid
I would flip the camera around and take
a selfie of myself and hand it back to
them and then they would dip the hat
oh dude my favorite was when we were in
that haunted house and like it's dark as
[ __ ] and this lady looks right at Nikki
you should oh my god oh wait what it see
you know it was like Luke Setsubun is
like Kootenay Olivos has been the tasty
Tuesday it is Nikki and Steve are like
dude nikki has been okay there is this
one oh that's hard about this before
well maybe I have because it just always
comes to mind for me but there's one
night where we went out I think for
justice birthday and so it's all of us
like the whole gaggle of girls from the
[ __ ] podcast and Lyon Julia oh yeah
Julia was there and like but like as a
unit it feels like you would probably
like we're fairly recognizable like
you're confirming like it's not like oh
is that them it's like oh that's
definitely them that would happen to me
though yeah but like Mickey's the only
person that got ready all night and
we're at the door and he's like look at
RIT he's like oh [ __ ] you're like famous
any like how they're doing he's like no
she's famous like like just like geo is
there like she is like way more like
Mickey Watson and then like we start
walking in there like man ID ID ID
you're not with miss Li mo are you it's
a dice roll man that's a dice fool you
never know you never know what they saw
you from yeah exactly I didn't want to
ask either one time this was like back
in like 2011 I had my ex-boyfriend do
you know the Upright Citizens Brigade
theater okay so it's like hard to like
be in that click where you can invite it
to the New Year's party instead there's
a quick thing there's only person that
invited and he had a plus-one and he was
so excited he was like we're gonna roll
into it he got all like dressed up he
said we're gonna roll in there and like
I got invited you're my plus-one and
then I roll we were all in there and
they were like yo you Nicky Lima
oh yeah I saw your huge it's totally
scattered stuff back until this guy's
did and and he like God yeah see it's
it's cute that Nikki remembers a from
2011 it happens me so often okay it's
okay I should just always be Nikki and
Steve yeah we're gonna see Steve Lima
actually think before that very much the
famous person at the end of tasty
Tuesday right yeah yeah yeah the guy
that tastes the drinks yeah it's funny
you get that experience though because
when people I'm alone and people come up
to me they're always like hey can you
tell Steve blah blah blah blah blah like
they do that yeah yeah no I'm sane I
mean they just have it a danger boys to
me it's like telling me I love her so
much and I'm like why right here [ __ ]
I think it was a guy a few months ago or
a few weeks ago when I was doing David's
podcast we were walking around Pasadena
we went to grab a lunch before that and
we're just walking down the street and I
see this
screaming fan in a bakery literally
flailing her arms she might be watching
this hello lady
literally flailing her arms and she was
like with a parent or something I was
like David I was like it she's like
mouthing boom just starts pouring out
you know when she passed out there's an
ambulance
hey I'm like so caught off-guard by this
because I've never seen son it was like
Backstreet Boys 2002 okay
and David just like kind of just keeps
walking and I'm like David he was like
happens all the time
come on David David just like kind of
walking by just okay no I love bands
like that because I'm like okay cool at
least I know that you're excited versus
just like standing from afar and just be
like well that's pretty weird
yes I hate that I hate that somebody
tried to take a picture of me out of
mainland poke a the other day and I
immediately turned around because the
guy was with my boyfriend at the time
and I'm just like dude what the [ __ ]
like I'm on like a date like can you
chill about and he's just like a sneak
of it he was like this he was like so
[ __ ] fast I'm like sir nobody ever
actually like talks to me like they'll
just really like try to sneak it I think
because I originally like came from
Smosh so a lot of my fan base is from
Smosh and they're younger and maybe a
little more shocked than YouTube fans
yeah the real one
the JK fans are completely different oh
dude they're mad cool okay so one time
I'm in an uber I'm in I'm in an uber I
get in and this dude he's like hey like
yeah it's just for that I'm like yeah
and then he's like oh he's like well I
got charges if you need anything I was
like all right cool man and he was like
I got candy if you need anything going
and he like and sanitizer like blah blah
and I was like I was like thank you so
much I was like I'm good though and he
was like are you want YouTube it off and
I'm like this is like an older guy like
maybe late 30s or so and I'm just like
yes and he was like oh my god your bow
whose but he was a JK fan and he was
like mad cool that's why I like about JK
fans they're all older they're like most
of our fans are like from high school to
like even 40 or 50 it's the worst part
of our level of Fame though right is
that we usually have to fill in the
blanks for them it's like somebody comes
up to you and like like it's like papers
please right like it's it like Brad Pitt
will never have to do that in his life
Brad Pitt goes anywhere and they know
exactly why they're like holy [ __ ] it's
you I don't like I forget all the time
that I'm on the internet and like then
people will stare and I think they're
judging me for something else like I'm
like okay yeah like the hairs [ __ ] up
okay so like whatever
go outside with [ __ ] up hair or like
you know I think they're like they're
staring at me and I'm like am i walking
funny look what the [ __ ] it was why are
they staring at me and then Steve's like
oh I think that's a yeah i JK person
like that's [ __ ] awful somebody being
like hey from somewhere I know you from
interviewing yeah like um okay Dean have
you watched this and like now yeah all
right watch Shane Dawson back in the day
and they're like oh yeah all right used
to be his vlogs or whatever and I'm like
yeah there it is it's [ __ ] like that you
just cuz when you've been in the amount
of videos we've been the amount of
different youtubers and some people I
saw you on raywilliamjohnson I saw you
from Shane yes sometimes like JK news
they're like no I'm like tipsybartender
like oh [ __ ] tipsy bartender cuz we
collaborate with so many people I always
get Wong foo lot yeah Minna Wong foo
video oh I see but I'm also they also
mix up JK with Wong foo so yeah dude was
saying that one of her neighbors was a
JK person but didn't even know that she
was part of JK so it's like he was
asking her like about like what they do
for a living and stuff and took
mentioned like having a YouTube channel
and she's like and he's like oh like
Wong foo and then she's like yeah
actually you I know them we're friends
and they're like oh yeah like I watched
them through JK from JK fella and she's
like yeah put them two and he's like oh
I might have seen you before has he
never watched you do well we've been on
for 13 years so it depends on the
generation like you know when we had the
danger boy screening like I would say a
good 80% of them remember the old school
but a lot of people didn't raise their
hands when we talked about JK films
mm-hmm
a lot of people probably know us from JK
news or JK party because there are
people that come in from JK party and
then they watch JK news they didn't even
know we had skits yeah and then there's
the old school fans that watched our
skits and it stopped there because it
would stop me in a stream be like hey
man I watched those videos like are you
guys still making videos
you know what's wild is sometimes people
would be like I used to watch you in
middle school and they're like a grown
ass 25 year old someone who said they
were six yeah they were six at the time
yeah she was like my uncle who's 13 at
the time I'm like a 13 year old
she says her and him she was six years
old he was 13 they would watch JK films
and I'm like and we really cultivated
some young minds very young kid there
too and I was like there was a child and
I was like I hope that he has some kind
of syndrome otherwise this but there
were three of them you remember that
yeah it was like one you know like the
Three Stooges and [ __ ] like a Wi-Fi
signal yeah and then they were like yeah
and he was conceived to JK news I end up
all right it was two fans that met up
and then they created a JK baby kind of
disgust but didn't even give him a JK
name so whatever actually yeah you had
you you mean you dated another JK fan
you have to name it after one of us no
if ands or buts that's through our list
a middle name like a Julia middle name
or something I've seen a JK couple who's
met in the comments that got matching
tattoos it's time to comment I was Jose
like our old JK logo yeah I think my
favorite fans are the ones were like
I'll do I'm a huge fan and then they
like see your name wrong and I'm like no
thanks for being like Tiffany right I
got that they caught me in like yo Seth
Green I get I get Julia lava-like you're
close enough but at the same time like
but if you say that you're my biggest
fan fan appreciation on you that's why
we're not sweating you in the book we
are not famous people no but I like this
though man well I like I like how we can
just like be humans and going shop I
would never want to be that level of
those kids want to do it's like a secret
that we all have with our fans because
like they see us and they're like I know
it's like all right we guys like Fight
Club
yes yeah it's like all right cool and
sometimes bartenders are buy you drinks
cuz they used to watch each other
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you